let's make burgers
welcome back to burger scholar
headquarters i have to tell you i really
miss being on the road i mean i like
being here with you people i really
really miss travel and getting out there
and eating burgers with amazing people
in far-off places so today we're going
to take an imaginary trip to australia
today we're going to explore a
controversial icon of australian cuisine
the burger with the lot you've heard of
it before i'm sure wait and you see what
goes on this thing it's crazy i'm always
happy to see what happens to the
american burger when it goes abroad like
the islak burger and turkey buff
sandwich of denmark and the sloppy
burger of malaysia there's fierce debate
about what should be on the burger with
the lot but there's one ingredient that
has to be on the burger to make it an
official aussie burger and that is
ready for this one beetroot that's right
this burger includes that earthy tuber
mmm everyone's favorite beetroot and
there are some very outspoken critics of
this burger like chef david chang who
once famously said australians [ __ ] up
burgers more than anyone in the world
i'm not here to judge i'm here to make
the burger that they love so much but
first let's talk to someone in australia
who knows his burgers my friend jimmy
hurlston in melbourne what's up buddy
[Music]
that's what i've got here
[Music]
it's your book jimmy is the is the me of
australia i'm flattered
jimmy
the big question i have for you other
than why why
but what is going on what elements
should there be at the very bare minimum
in burger with the lot george you and i
both the great is definitely somewhat of
a travesty when it comes to hamburgers
but
i think you've got to have
beetroot it's crucial
egg is crucial
and pineapple is essential
you're always going to have an issue
finding one of the ingredients the bacon
that they use in australia do you mean
rashers yeah middle rashes from the
lying part of the of the pig ketchup and
barbecue sauce sometimes uh and a
seeded bun sesame seeds on a bun i'm
gathering this as an iconic burger but
is it really i mean is it is it is it
surrounded with pride is it like
swimming with nostalgia
there's a hell of a lot of nostalgia
absolutely if you talk about talk to a
young person about a burger and what
they expect in a burger in australia
you'll get a description but if you do
it in front of their parents their
parents are going to chime in and say
what do you mean there's no egg on that
burger it's no good if it doesn't have
egg and beetroot burger with a lot or
forget about it mate don't worry about
it
[Music]
thank you so good talking to you
my pleasure on your cub
you ever you have a bloody ripper right
let's make a burger this burger has a
lot of crazy ingredients
what the [ __ ] on there
little flag in there hello three things
happening first three oh [ __ ]
sorry salt your patties
it's gotta be big
cook a couple of rashers well we're
using bacon butter and toast
this part is
burgers arrived in australia in the
1930s with greek immigrants but not from
greece they actually immigrated from the
united states this checks out because
greeks were very influential in starting
the hamburger business in the u.s
of iceberg lettuce on the bottom on top
of that a tomato some sliced pickled
beetroot i'm using pickled beetroots to
taste a little bit better the
traditional way to use beetroot on a
burger is not pickled let's talk about
beetroot why is there beetroot on this
burger we do know
that beetroot was in surplus 1920s and
30s in australia and at some point it's
believed that australians put beetroot
on a burger and fed it to us marines
were stationed in australia in the 1950s
as a joke
and it's stuck
whoops
and now of course decades later there's
nothing but pride with beetroot on a
burger cheese
okay put the rashes these are grilled
onions i gotta cook an egg this is gonna
be kind of complicated
i don't know how they time this [ __ ]
okay take this off of here look at that
i didn't burn myself
yeah
crack an egg
what's happening next i forgot oh the
[ __ ] pineapple a slice of pineapple
then the burger patty
holy [ __ ] look at that so now
onto the top of the bun inside here i'm
gonna put barbecue sauce oh [ __ ] i just
knocked it over
jesus
you australians are wacky i tell you oh
sorry that was really [ __ ] hot if
you're in sydney for example they use
barbecue sauce okay egg
on top of this
ah
there we go
how's this
wish me luck people i'm going in face
first
oh oh god oh yeah okay i got this
i got this
people are insane i tell you
uh-huh
um
oh man
it's actually good
beetroot
that's good
not too weird
burger with a lot
very good
but i need to come to australia invite
me to australia and i'll come and eat
the real thing with you there's a lot
more to know out there there's a lot
more knowledge to know i am not an
all-knowing burger scholar i am
constantly learning constantly testing
and researching and finding out things
thank you
i'll see you next time when i make a
burger i can actually put in my mouth
hey thanks for watching burger scholar
sessions you should like and subscribe
to this channel but also get more
episodes up here
somewhere in here right there
yeah watch more episodes right here